podemos formarme si la tos y tos y la
tos a partir de alcohol y los mesilato
citó si la tos son buenos grupos
salientes veamos la reacción general
para la formación de un tos y la pto
empezaremos con un alcohol y agregaremos
cloruro de tos hilo y piri bean para
obtener nuestro tos y lado de la derecha
echemos un vistazo al mecanismo
empezaremos con nuestro cloruro de tos y
lo observen que el azufre está unido a
dos oxígenos y un cloro que son más
electro negativos que el azufre entonces
retiran un poco de densidad electrónica
así que el azufre es parcialmente
positivo es un electro filo el azufre
quiere electrones y podrá obtener los
del alcohol así que un par de electrones
ataca para nuestro azufre y estos
electrones se irán junto con el cloro
para formar el año en cloruro dibujemos
lo que nos queda tenemos un grupo r y
unido al oxígeno tenemos el azufre
un hidrógeno y un par de electrones
libres lo que le da al oxígeno una carga
formal positiva el azufre está unido con
un doble enlace a este oxígeno
y a este oxígeno y por acá tenemos el
anillo con sus electrones pitt y un
grupo metilo sigamos a los electrones
estos electrones en rosa formaron este
enlace con el azufre
en el siguiente paso necesitamos es pro
tornar al oxígeno así que nuestra purina
funcionará como una base este par de
electrones toma este protón dejando
estos electrones en el oxígeno dibujemos
el resultado tenemos el grupo r y ahora
nuestro oxígeno tiene dos pares de
electrones libres
después tenemos el azufre dos oxígenos
nuestro anillo y el grupo metilo
entonces los electrones en este enlace
son los que se quedaron en el oxígeno
así hemos formado nuestro esther tolueno
sulfonato también conocido como tos y la
pto
estos dos compuestos son exactamente lo
mismo pero esta es una forma de
apreciarlo al formar un dócil ato
podemos tener una mejor reacción de
sustitución núcleo física primero veamos
la formación de un dócil ato a partir de
este alcohol sabemos que este carbono es
un centro girar pero cuando formamos
puntos hilado sólo afectamos al oxígeno
dibujemos el producto aún tenemos una
cuña y tenemos el oxígeno unido altos y
lo hemos formado un grupo tos y la tos
que es mejor grupo saliente que el h
entonces podemos hacer una reacción de
sustitución núcleo física agregaremos
algo como bromuro de sodio enea más
r - y si hacemos el mecanismo por la vía
es n 2 el bromuro atacará a este carbono
que es parcialmente positivo así que el
núcleo fi lo ataca justo aquí dibujemos
el producto como la reacción ocurre por
la vía sn 2 hay una inversión de la
configuración ahí está entonces la
formación de un tos y la tos hace que
todo esto sea más fácil ahora hablemos
de la formación de otro buen grupo
saliente el mesilato es muy parecido al
tos y la tos
si analizamos la reacción general
nuevamente empezaremos con un alcohol y
esta vez agregaremos cloruro de metilo y
triet y la mina que funcionará como una
base para finalmente formar nuestro
mesilato del lado derecho
el mecanismo es un poco diferente al de
la formación de un tos y la tos vamos a
ver primero nuestra triet y la mina
funcionará como base y tomará este
protón dejando estos electrones en el
carbono así que nuestra trichet y lámina
reacciona con el cloruro de metilo y nos
queda nuestro azufre unido con un doble
enlace a un oxígeno por aquí y otro por
acá también está unido a un cloro y
luego tenemos un carbono unido a dos
hidrógenos con un par de electrones
libres es un carbón
así que los electrones en este enlace se
quedaron en el carbono para formar el
carbón en el siguiente paso estos
electrones en rosa se moverán hacia acá
para formar un doble enlace entre el
carbono y el azufre empujando a estos
electrones que se irán junto con el
cloro para formar el a nyon cloruro
dibujemos lo que nos queda tenemos
nuestro azufre unido a 2 oxígenos y
ahora tenemos un doble enlace entre el
azufre y este carbón que a su vez está
unido a dos hidrógenos
ahora podemos pensar en que el azufre es
electro físico porque está unido a estos
oxígenos que son más electro negativos
retiran densidad electrónica
entonces el azufre es parcialmente
positivo es un electro filo y nuestro
alcohol puede funcionar como núcleo filo
entonces un par de electrones atacará a
nuestro electro filo empujando estos
electrones
eso al carbono dibujemos el resultado
tenemos un grupo r unido a un oxígeno
que está unido a un hidrógeno este es el
oxígeno de nuestro alcohol que atacó a
nuestro azufre y tenemos un enlace entre
el oxígeno y el azufre y un par de
electrones libres en el oxígeno lo que
le da una carga formal positiva el
azufre está unido a 2 oxígenos
y aún carbono que a su vez está unido a
dos hidrógenos
y tiene un par de electrones libres
entonces estos electrones se movieron
hacia el carbono para reformar nuestro
avión y los electrones en nuestro
alcohol estos electrones en rojo
formaron un enlace entre el oxígeno y el
azufre en el último paso del mecanismo
el carbón
funcionará como una base este par de
electrones toma este protón dejando
estos electrones en el oxígeno dibujemos
el resultado tenemos un grupo r
un oxígeno con dos pares de electrones
libres
el azufre que está unido con un doble
enlace a todos oxígenos y de este lado
tenemos un ch 3 porque este carbono tomó
este protón digamos que es este protón
hemos formado nuestro mesilato y lo
podemos abreviar como
r&m ese entonces así podemos formarme si
la tos y tos y la tos que son excelentes
grupos salientes